i got to tell you what else i'm envious
of man that i can only hope to
experience
in some type of way you know as i get
older
i got four kids now right and of course
you wonder what your kids are going to
do how your kids are going to grow up
what are they going to want to do with
their careers their lives etc
uh o'shea man oh man o'shea like you
know
it's a little surreal it's crazy for a
movie to be created based off of
your life right
your
your group your foundation
and to tell a story
about the good the bad
and the disgustingly ugly like to tell
that story
and to have your son
cast it
and knock the roll out the park man i
mean crazy i mean cute what what does
that feel like what what is that what is
that
give me a clear description of how that
makes you feel
i mean you know
like
you don't walked out one time you felt
like your balls was like
huge yeah yeah yeah that's what it feels
it felt like
you know like
i got basketballs right now hold on this
is
and and look it's it's so cool
you know
to have him
you know be in the movie and do a great
job and organically
be the best person for the part
that that's to me what i'm proud of is
i got him ready
but he had to
do it he had to get the job he had to
have
you know donna langley
you know give the stamp of approval
not me you know what i'm saying so
uh and there was other actors when you
say you got him ready what does that
mean though i approached him and um
and said look
i think we're gonna do this in wa movie
and
i want you to play me
now i had took him on tour
we didn't you know he'd been on stage
with me doing the nwa songs i've been
you know i've been watching him from
there i'm like
this kid got it
and so
he was like yeah yeah yeah that'd be
cool but i thought he was like
you know i'm like okay
i'm about to put your ass through the
ringer
and if you don't want to play me you're
going to quit like you know what i'm
saying because i don't want you to get
there get on the screen and not be ready
so
like i did send him the acting uh
classes la new york
um and he was
you know where i was thinking he was
gonna be like man i'm tired you know i
don't feel like going in or you know
trying to ditch the little classes he
was like no no i got to get with my
coach you know i mean i mean he's
supposed to go through some stuff and so
he was like getting he embraced it yeah
embraced it and was uh
i'm like oh he working hard so then i
had to tell gary gary gray
i'm like
gary guess what man i got something to
tell you
he said it's because he's ready you know
we in pre-production we getting ready
you know he's he's tired we you know
universal
green litter just ready and i'm like
dude i got to tell you something i said
i want my son to play me hmm
he was like
damn cute
man i thought we was making a real movie
that's what he said too i was like
we are making a real move
i said we are making a real movie and i
said and he gonna be great in it and
you're gonna help him be great just like
john singleton helped me be great damn
you gonna do the same thing he did for
me damn
and uh he was like
all right all right let let me see what
he got
and so
you know they went to you know he put
him through the ringer i mean it's been
like two years now
you know of auditions of pra of prep two
years of practice two years from dad
throwing you through it and now now
we're doing more okay so now it's the
screen
test time
um it's five other ice cubes there too
just in case
and my son said when he saw that that's
made that made him more mad than
anything like
oh y'all think y'all about to
[Music]
yeah so now he's thinking of like i got
to do this for the family
so
he'd get in there and get the part you
know and then
you know did what he what it took
to be great you know when the cameras
start rolling you know it's cool to be
you know you had them actors who
they do everything great until the damn
cameras start rolling and then they
frozen so and the dopest thing is that
he didn't just take the moment he sees
the opportunity i mean o'shea is now
he's now a working actor in hollywood he
do
bigger movies than me a respected one he
do bigger movies than me i mean he do
godzilla
he ain't star wars he's a star wars yeah
yeah man like
he's a respected working actor in
hollywood
i think that's an amazing thing to have
your son portray your life
and and do an amazing job of it
[Music]
gold
[Music]